all right let's do it all right everyone
what's up
what's up Alan sake analyst simulation
here over with my buddy ed really hey ed
thanks for coming in and showing me this
demo I really appreciate it we're going
live right now so that we can experience
we real where's newest equipment so this
equipment is mixed reality for industry
so what that means is that we're having
workers like in the construction
industry that are able to use a product
like this without they're without
needing to occupy their hands they're
able to augment the reality that is
within front of their face it's it's
quite like a mixed reality something
with more so you're seeing through this
IP so I'll show it to you later I'm
gonna try and show it to you but so I
can do things like navigate through
things so right now I can go my files
and right now what just happened is I'm
navigating through a bunch of data upon
files right now iPhoto so right now I'm
gonna look at what do I say for looking
at for goodness and then what I say if
we're looking at full photo for select
item for all right so now I'm looking at
an actual blueprint and so now I can go
zoom level five listen I'm really soon
din on this blueprint and I can go
freeze document and then that enables me
to move so I was browsing it with my
head and then now I froze it so now I'm
gonna observe it do work that kind of
stuff and then and then we'll do control
document and then that unfreezes it and
I can move my head around keep looking
at it navigate home and then if I get a
phone call I can take the phone call
from right here I can call people like
that from right here also we can go to
my camera and then from here I can zoom
level five zoom level one
and you zoom level one and then you
could have changed between zoom levels
and you can really be able to take a
photo and save it in your archives and
access it at a later time what are the
programs that are really important the
remote assistance does you see what
exactly yes you look at your video take
a video I see what you're looking at you
fix the problem go and if you get in
trouble I can help use the expert and
that's called control decision remote
assistance and yes so that that is
obviously of the major thing here is
that I get to use this while being
remotely assisted by somebody else when
I don't know exactly how to pursue do
the next step really really because
there is a there is a 16 let's take this
off so we can show you guys now some of
the some of the features maybe we can
even get into camera let's let us
actually try will actually show up who
maybe will be close oh my god can I see
it I might be I just you have something
loaded that's here I can't see it it's
close but that gives them a general gist
maybe they get a document there so yeah
yeah that's they use you like a general
gist you know there's power button here
multiple languages ten languages there
select from here's um here's your 16
megapixel camera right there and so
that's what they would be viewing if
they were assisting you yeah that high
high high definition camera you sit
there and yeah the person with the other
end where they're on a computer camera
or tablet they could see what you're
looking at and you provide them
assistance no matter where you are
whether you're in medical space energy
and gas power that sort of thing
anywhere you have expertise that you
want to bring expertise to the field
that's a device like this does for you
is awesome
bringing that expertise to the field
remotely okay and then the battery life
is if you're
on a call it's like three oh yeah it's
about three hours when you're doing a
video call and if you're just looking at
your documents or your content that you
will score on here you have 16 to 256
mega or gigs of storage of memory mm-hmm
so you have a lot of storage on there if
you're just living the content you can
go about eight hours and if you're
looking at if you're doing home motion
video and that sort of thing about three
hours
it's a hot swappable battery too so you
can extend the life of better just pop
the battery out put a new one in there's
right here you ask
let's Harvard let's take that battery
right out we have a little 50 mil and
battery on board so you drop that out
put a new one in and then you're off one
more time again boom boom just like that
is um that's a great that's good
engineering now this is being used this
is this is about you know actually quick
guys you want to say that what's really
nice that I like a lot about it is that
it's very comfortable most augmented
reality headsets are not comfortable
because they rest only on your forehead
and all a bum cap or a hard hat offer
yeah and that's and that's that's this
is again that's probably one of my
favorite parts is just how comfortable
it is in comparison to other arguments
or even mixed reality headsets navigate
home and so another interesting thing is
for cost wise it's about 1500 bucks for
one of these HB T's which stands for
head mounted tablet HP t1 had marked a
tablet one and they are they're being
used by other over a couple in just the
last one four months now you guys have
sold a multiple thousands the full rated
production in mid-december so once we
get a full rate production restarted
launching legs it's been in development
for quite some time a number of years
and they had a nice pilot program and
they executed a pilot program for both
you know most of 2016 and went really
heavy in 17 and now we're looking for
going from proofs of concept actual
rollouts in industrial users and it's
being used by Manitoba where you see
some nice videos from ferry electric on
YouTube ferry electrode Manitoba Hydra
on YouTube you can check out what
they're doing with the devices right now
yeah that's great so this has been a fun
demo from real where
thank you guys for coming and for
showing me this I really appreciate it
and hopefully we can get some some more
love your way because I'm sure there are
people across our platform that are
interested in so it's not free in your
hand free in your hands up yeah and
getting the remote assistant your hands
has read yeah all right bye everyone